open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money J is
in Fort Worth Texas
hi J how are you I'm doing great how are
you better than I deserve what's up yes
sir so little background I've started
your plan back in March and since then I
have a second job so I'm working about
80 hours a week I've paid off just about
$35,000 so far this year and now I'm was
we went to your smart conference here in
Dallas and was reading one of the books
last night and decided that it's time to
get rid of my car I went to Kelly Blue
Book we've got a estimate and I know I'm
upside down I'm upside down quite a bit
at about $18,000 upside down
whoa how in the world so I have had a
really bad habit of trading in my car
just about every single year I was 18
years old
so you've rolled negative equity every
time into it yeah so it's not just this
car it's all the bad deals up to this
point rolled into one absolutely this
one was probably the worst they told me
that my body style had gone out today
and if I didn't trade it in I would be
losing money every day on the car and so
make one final mistake in this one but
I've decided to turn this around I went
to a local credit union today and they
actually told me my best option would be
a home equity loan because getting
18,000 on just a personal loan the
interest rate would be really high and
it's unsecured so they wouldn't they
didn't like that deal I showed them my
debt snowball and what I've paid off
this year and they said that's all
really good but with that amount they're
looking at some other options and I just
wasn't comfortable with putting my home
at that point so I know I'm not either
you know they're going to give me a good
Reyes from your credits clean it's it's
getting there for sure it's gone up you
know about 50 points since I started
this plan just paying everything off
okay so it's not talking they're still
talking about nine percent they didn't
run a credit application but they said
that's about where it would be nine
percent equity loan or on a personal
loan on a personal loan okay now they
recommended the home equity yeah and
yeah your household income is what with
my part-time job I'm making just about a
hundred thousand but my part-time job
all 2,000 of that's been going to debt
every single month and and how much debt
do you have total not counting the house
total left I have including the car
eighty so I've got about thirty-eight
left to pay on other stuff so what are
you owe in the car
forty-two holy okay um let's see here
and eighteen of that is the negative
equity so if you sold the car and
borrowed eighteen thousand dollars to do
that what are you driving um a very
cheap one thousand dollar car that you
have or that you're going to get now I'm
just going to use my emergency fund to
just buy and then rebuild up next
month's income so you might end up
borrowing nineteen thousand as what it
amounts to which is okay at least that's
better than forty two so that cuts your
debt uh well it cuts it by twenty five
thousand bucks right yeah and my my
payoff date is August 2018 that's where
I'm at now but I think if I did this I'd
be able to do it easily by June of next
year yeah I'm doing the personal loan
and I'm going to pay the higher interest
rate I don't want your home pledged for
this mess I'd rather to be unsecured
debt and yeah because the interest rates
are not going to matter much given how
fast you're going to pay it off okay and
we're get we're just getting rid of big
chunks of debt yeah I'm with you I think
that's what you do but I wouldn't I
would not do I wouldn't give him the
deed to the house I would want to get
Moline on the house okay and I don't is
your again it's $18,000 you're not going
to have the loan out
long and so the difference in that
you're paying is very very little very
little so hey I hope that helps thanks
for calling this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below